we have new swing State polling and I
want to be really clear about this this
is general election swing State polling
which finds that Ron DeSantis would do
better against Joe Biden than would
Donald Trump
this does not mean the Republican magats
are going to choose someone other than
Trump to be their nominee
this doesn't mean any of that Trump is
still the most likely Republican nominee
it just means that Trump's claim that he
would beat Biden where DeSantis would
lose is not borne out by the facts why
do we care about swing States we care
about swing States because whether it's
DeSantis or Trump Joe Biden's going to
win California whether it's DeSantis or
Trump DeSantis or Trump are going to win
Wyoming okay the election is going to
come down to a group of Swing States in
those swing States we are increasingly
getting data that Ron DeSantis would do
better against Joe Biden than would
Donald Trump I'm not giving advice to
Republicans I'm just telling you this is
what the data shows if you look at a new
poll out of Pennsylvania you find that
Biden leads Trump but DeSantis leads by
it remember these are hypothetical
matchups where you say to people if it
were Trump versus Biden who do you vote
for if it were Des Sanctus versus Biden
who do you vote for and people respond
in Georgia of an important state that
Joe Biden won in 2020 unusually so for
Democrats in recent years in Georgia
Biden leads Trump but DeSantis leads
Biden in Arizona another really
important State uh Biden leads Trump but
DeSantis leads Biden let's see what else
we have from swing states that may be it
for a recent once uh oh Michigan in
Michigan Biden and Trump are tied
DeSantis leads Biden very small margin
and statistically probably a dead heat
so the important takeaway here is that
the Republican electorate right now it's
June 27th right this could change Trump
gets arrested a third or fourth time
DeSantis comes up with some free pony
plan that everybody loves all of a
sudden free zebras who knows it could
change the point right now is in these
very important contested States swing
States
DeSantis is polling better than Trump
against the most likely Democratic
nominee Joe Biden
so it might be the logical thing for
Republicans to select someone with a
better shot at winning but they seem
determined to select Donald Trump